I could tell my voice is gone but we got
a special guest he's performing tonight
Janice live yeah - good to be true tour
yeah August Alsina in the building would
it do do first things first I want to
thank you as an RB fan mm-hmm because
I've been so tired of all these are be
artists doing these damn fist pump
records these pop records in finally we
got some good R&B man somebody I just
left somebody else just I just had the
same conversation with this other guy
and it's coming from men right so that's
like that's love and in respect it
should be that you know if you get to
pop it man don't don't jump on an order
on like a Afrojack because I can't give
you what come alone with the you know
pop music I can't flip across the stage
and all that so I'm crying hey what's up
with you and strippers man strippers
love you bro you make these strip club
records and do strippers you know they
make a lot of money to your songs I hope
that I could get a percentage they
making all that money but not really I
think I got a some type of connection
with a few stripper girls day you know
they my friends I guess quote-unquote
okay um so you smash a couple strippers
I mean you know they but I feel like I
always say a stripper to me is kind of
the equivalent to somebody to a man
selling drugs I agree you know I'm
saying cuz I'm out you doing what I got
to do to survive but at the same time I
don't feel like it should be a cop out I
feel like if you're gonna do that you
got to do that to get on your feet next
where you trying to go like this but
nowadays a lot of girls they just been
like pissing me off because it's like
this all they know and they want to blow
up off of being a stripper since we
don't come cool since Instagram Wow
Instagram got these strippers feel some
type of way so should the in in a Big
Dig I'm thinking Instagram guy got it
thinking that they models yep because
you know cuz it cuz you're a normal ass
female that post enough pictures of her
ass or
a hundred thousand followers on a second
but but the thing is you post the
picture of your s and you only get about
fifteen hundred likes how does that make
you feel the worst is the caption that
they put it like just woke up I know
what you doing but I think I think some
strip is a cool girl they got a good
night frame in and I use you for a while
so ya know you you know all of them like
this it is what it is I mean they can't
hide and they naked in front of you so
they got him so now it's not one of my
favorite joints from you is the ghetto
record man is great way to me talk about
the struggle man that you embody in your
music like you know what I'm saying
where you from and how important it is
for you to represent you know I mean I
represent like I tell people all the
time in my show I represent the struggle
I understand the struggle like I'm from
the hood I represent two ghetto and you
know I gotta put that in my music
because that's all I know
yeah I'm saying I can only sing what I
live and kind of hope that is spiritual
healing for somebody that it touched
somebody in it
I mean it's paying off because you know
my music touch people and a whole lot of
different ways in just the stuff that
people come you know come up to me and
tell me like I was doing a
meet-and-greet you know I always talk
about this one do because it was just
crazy a bunch of girls in line I figure
out what city I was in a bunch of girls
in line and you know I see it's a few
dudes in there and you know they're
coming up to take pictures and I see the
dude and he's like his he cast it up
right so he came up and he was like man
I just had to tell you that you save you
saved my life like your video came on
and uh while I was in the hospital
downtown came on while I was in the
hospital and you you helped me get
through my surgery and all that he said
you got shot ten times
you know yeah like that's what this all
about like that's what I do it felt like
you know and it ain't nothing more
special than that you know
say hey you know what man there's like
like it's different because I feel like
a lot of a lot of dudes who do RB it's
it's hard I mean I feel like harm be in
general it's hard for a lot of men like
to embrace it you don't have Sam yeah
but there's always that like a life
Jennings or like yourself that you know
I'm saying it like cats who real cats
really really can relate to you I'm
saying me cuz you know what it is is the
the problem is at least I believe that a
lot of times were artists if you don't
have a vision for yourself somebody else
gonna give you big have a vision they
gonna make you be something that you're
not and that you can't keep that up
forever so it's like why not come in the
game bro and just be who you are you
know I'm saying this if you like it you
like it if you don't you just don't mean
and that's just what it is like you
can't be out you're faking it you know
flattens it trying to be something
you're not and because I honestly
honestly believed that leads to failure
nobody came back with that 100% man all
right so you're early in your career
yeah you are still on the come-up you
know people are still learning about you
yeah but I know that you that you have
had some groupie experiences already
this has got to have have happened
uh-huh
can you I don't want to say groupie but
can you kind of give us a wild story
that you have encouraged so far on this
journey that might involve a thirsty
female or two I don't know
well man this is actually it's a little
more dangerous than a one-night thing
right girls are crazy
yeah yeah they are girls aggressive you
know girls follow you literally on
Twitter Instagram and in-person believe
it in a steal I mean I this you say they
steal they definitely still this chick I
thought she was cool for a second right
she showed me her true colors she uh I
was sleep she was she got you she came
to my hotel door okay and it's late and
she she was knocking and I just never
let her in because I was going to sleep
yeah
and um she like just walked in my room
so I just lost my mind cuz I'm like how
the hell did you get in here yo that's
crazy
so yes she was in that befo and ended up
still in the key boy either she pieced
the security up and told them like not
as my man you not saying he's sleeping
so hard and she came in and act like she
was supposed to be there and what was
even worse she just had a calm the meat
she had to meet you it was like no it's
okay so so you kicked her out
oh definitely she didn't steal any of
your belongings though just the room key
no I just just just just just the key
but before she did have my things that I
had this in female goons yeah yeah you
know they'll take care of business I
will look you got this record it's
called num it's you know from the west
coast yeah this is this is got that West
Coast
ratchet sound you know that that mustard
there's the beat you got Yo Gotti on you
got Bo Bo on it yeah it's a monster
record strippers are probably already
making their their their money to this
you know what I'm saying but yo let's
get into a man introduce you new single
my brother I appreciate you coming
through you already notes August I've
seen them in and this is my single think
until you gonna put my dog Bo being Yo
Gotti right yeah yeah go get that out
man what's the call what can I get it
testimony is in stores April 15 is
actually going up for pre-order on
anyway wait you already got something in
stores right now though right I got my
EP okay my EP I dropped the EP but now
it's album time April 15 is cut
testimony and you can make sure you cut
that it's a pre-order tonight midnight
oh right midnight man we pre warden that
day man we're gonna celebrate with some
shots tonight about Southwest